preneur il va falloir s'habituer à lui
verser l'union rugby centre 60,18 né de
la fusion entre deux clubs
le sky rugby et montigny le bretonneux
sous leurs nouvelles couleurs bleu noir
vers l'ue rcd yvelines dans son histoire
avec une victoire bonifiée
score final 32 à 13 face au red star 2 5
points
on se bouffe et de plaisir puisque on
partait un peu dans l'inconnu
on savait pas où on en était on va bien
travailler depuis un mois un mois et
demi et puis on voit que que l'état
d'esprit est là c'est c'était l'un des
fondements sur lesquels on va s'appuyer
état d'esprit et aujourd'hui on a eu
l'état d'esprit et puis on a eu on a eu
un peu de volume de jeu donc on est très
satisfait
les unionistes saint quentinois ont bien
entamé la rencontre
il profite des fautes de saint-ouen pour
se procurer des pénalités des erreurs
techniques des visiteurs pour inscrire
un essai le rcmn rapidement 11 à 3 mais
juste avant la fin de la première
période les yvelinois se font surprendre
par le red star
les passes sont dans le timing et envoie
le numéro 15 a laissé le score à la mi
temps 11 à 10 au retour des vestiaires
le rc 78 reprend le jeu en main et suite
à une touche les trois quarts lance une
combinaison et le capitaine pierre
martin transperce la défense et s'en va
inscrire un nouvel essai entre les
poteaux
c'est des combis qu'on a de travailler
mais c'est vrai que derrière on a des
joueurs qui ont du ballon même si le
groupe en toc tel apport est pas encore
très très très très bon on va dire sur
la notion de groupe il ya beaucoup
d'individualités qui font que quand on
va aller très loin et le groupe va se
former très rapidement les unionistes
vont ensuite subir les assauts de
saint-ouen et vont commettre beaucoup de
fautes en défense
ils vont être réduits à quatorze
plusieurs fois à cause de deux cartons
le groupe renoir aujourd'hui c'est qu'on
a pas su défendre sans faire de faute
donc à chaque fois qu'ils avaient le
ballon haut qui nous met un peu de
pression on a fait beaucoup de fautes
sur défaut de hors jeu soit des photos
au niveau de la zone plaqueur plaqué
il faut qu'on apprenne à défendre sans
faire de fautes et on récupère lé ballon
avec l'entrée des remplaçants lui verser
va inscrire deux nouveaux essais et
s'imposer en fin de rencontre pas encore
d'objectif précis fixés cette saison
juste le plaisir de jouer ensemble au
sein de l'union rugby 178
[Applaudissements]